prepare with a final installment of the
Twilight franchise that tweens and
lonely moms have been waiting for and
the dads could not care less about
Twilight Breaking Dawn parts 1 & 2 the
tedious book that was turned into too
bloated movies just to squeeze more
money from gullible women featuring the
wedding that attempts to justify the
franchise's creepy pedophilia because
remember he's like a hundred years old
and she's still a teenager and the
honeymoon where mouth-breather and
shovel face finally have sex only to
immediately get pregnant prompting the
pro-life message that abortion is never
okay the fetus is it good for Bella save
the word Alice baby even when a monster
vampire baby tries to eat itself out of
its mother's womb and creating an awful
new baby name for an entire generation
of teen moms husband - weird witness
Teen Wolf
finally getting over dead eyes by
instead falling in love with a creepy
CGI baby should I start calling your dad
gross but when mouth-breather nearly
dies during childbirth
shovel face must transform her from a
human who can't act why can't you see
how perfect to a vampire who can't act
honestly even the movie had to teach her
how to act human at least three times a
minute
good brace yourself for two movies so
unnecessarily long that they include
five Volvo commercials - montages of the
previous Twilight movies four games of
chess and the most stairs ever
like seriously ever we counted and
suffer through four hours of painfully
stupid characters like this pack of dogs
who bark English would be French
we'll be able to control this curse the
Cullens who spend every movies standing
around watching people a grandfather who
doesn't notice that his own
granddaughter has aged eight years over
the course of a few months grown half a
foot and Kristen Stewart and her
inability to use toothpaste filmmaking
so lazy that vampires no longer Sparkle
even in direct sunlight sex ed is done
through Yahoo searches and the ultimate
climax of all five movies was all a
dream
that's your future what a ripoff
the story shovel face Skeletor Taylor
Swift Ron Burgundy North Dakota and snow
dogs Twilight Breaking Dawn so he's
gonna have to live with Kristen Stewart
forever I'd rather have my head ripped
off hey wanna do us a solid and revisit
all four honest Twilight trailers of a
your best friend I'm a Barbie girl in a
Barbie world life in plastic is
fantastic it's morphin time
winter is coming just what I thought I
was out they pull me back in the Human
Torch was denied a bank loan